with you darvish on the mound for the
padres 34 year old making his fifth
start i'll tell you what he's been
really really good the last three starts
seven innings strong each time out he
has kept the ball in the ballpark
of course he's got that cutter that
slider is forcing fastball buster has
been hot hitting 351 five home runs
with eight batted in a 4 13 on base
average and a curve buster drives one
into deep right field going back is
myers at the wall he looks up and
goodbye
an opposite field home run for buster
posey that curveball just kind of hung
there in the strike zone and buster went
with it
an opposite field home run not easy to
do at petco park
man he is must see tv right now
this this is just
the talk of the baseball world right now
i mean everybody knows this guy
everybody knows what he did
throughout most of his career until he
started having some
some injuries
on the hill is logan webb for the giants
24 year old making his fifth start he's
been back and forth he started the year
as a number three starter then went to
the bullpen then back because of an
injury
opponent sitting 294 and the splits are
unbelievable against the right-hander
logan webb two down grisham still at
second base and it brings up eric osmer
and that is a slow ground ball to the
right side mentioned le stella was deep
he's got a charge bare hand can't make
the play grisham coming in he will score
from second on a ground ball that didn't
even make it off the infield grass game
is tied one to one
just love the base running by trey
grisham here two outs he's moving on
contact
recognizes
that la stella's coming in basically
from right field
listello knows he has to bare hand this
ball in order to have a shot grisham
does not stop
one bit belt has four home runs so far
this year that is strike three bell
can't believe it
he is out number two of the fourth
inning
strikeout number six for darvish two
down and alex dickerson this one hit
over the shift into right field and deep
myers though going back has room and in
front of the morning track he's there to
make the catch hugh darvish has set down
ten in the row so haswerd a third pro
far to first on the fielder's choice now
two away and caratini coming up and the
pitch is outside ball four it's almost
as if from a body language perspective
karate knew there was no way he was
going to get a strike right there this
is filled with friars you is still
looking for his first hit in a padres
uniform here's a slider swung on and
missed strike three
webb gets him and after all of that some
very careful pitching by logan webb pays
off
so the giants have runners at second and
third but the pitcher's up now and he
strikes out second time that's happened
eight k's for darvish
stella struck you on the first and a
crown ball slowly to the right side
hosmer charging gonna be a little
awkward gets it reaches for him and tags
him out and darvish gets out of this
fifth inning without a run coming across
mike thompson has just hit a lead off
double here and now buster posey who's
driven in the only giant run is at the
plate who's swagging a mass had him out
in front of that splitter
and now nine strikeouts for you garbage
one away in the top of the sixth those
strikeouts he's had in any outing as a
padre after nine k's in each of his last
two outings talkman's still at second
and brandon belt coming up swinging a
miss and he struck him out back-to-back
cage for darvish ten and all two down to
the sixth inning darvish ahead one and
two that's strike three
ends up struggling on the side after
living off double he's got 11 strikeouts
at all you darvish has got it going on
at san diego tonight runners on second
and third one out pro far switch hitter
batting left handed over two lined to
center field a base set for profar
haswer will score here comes cronenworth
throw to the plate will be late two runs
in for the friars they take a 3-1 lead
jericho
driving in a pair
a two-run single for juricks and profar
and a critical juncture in this game
padres in front for the first time
tonight it's three to one
the ability to put away the first two
pitches that he disagreed with
and focusing on the task at hand
runners on second and third one out he's
down 02.
webb makes a mistake up in the zone
which is exactly where they wanted him
and he hits a missile right back up the
middle
two rbi single for jericho profile and
he is one strikeout away from setting a
franchise record for most strikeouts by
a padre pitcher through his first six
starts with the team longoria strikes
out for the third time tonight and there
you go a new padre record most
strikeouts by a padre pitcher in his
first six starts in a padre uniform
runners on first and second one out and
they're gonna leave him in with wilmer
flores coming up to pitch it and it is
just low and ball four back-to-back
walks the bases are loaded and that
probably seals darvish's fate so a pinch
hitter for the giants three to one san
diego in the seventh base is loaded and
one out ruff goes the other way
down the line into the corner
and
out of here
here and rough with a grand slam the
other way and the giants take the lead
the padres feel is not a home run
oh that's not even close so the umpires
are getting together right now they're
not reviewing it they're just talking at
the moment and it's a foul ball
that would have been a pretty dramatic
turn of events
had that been in fact a grand slam yeah
time for a reset huh yep not strike
three
two down to the seventh inning
huge strikeout for tim hill two outs and
here is mike talkman talkman swings and
misses strike three elevated fastball
and tim hill pumps his fist heads to the
dugout he strands all three runners
san francisco with the bases loaded
and nobody out and that is hit on one
hop to tatis knocked it down with the
chest shovels to quarterback one on the
first in time in the double play
posey comes in to score it is now a
three to two game but that one nearly
got away from the padre infield and a
great job by tati staying with it to get
the two outs
yeah we talked about mark malanson
in the pregame show our first hit in the
a block and he enters his 12th game
he is eight for eight and save
opportunities
and he's having one heck of a season in
the first month here opponents only
hitting 103 off of mark malanson and
what really jumps out only one walk in
12 innings two down and here's kurt
casalli that's in the air to straight
away center field playable for grisham
that is the ball game and that is a
winner padres take game one of the
series against the giants by a final of
three to two